[Music]
on this Thursday night surrender
America's 45th president arrested in
Atlanta where his loyal supporters are
standing by their man he's done
everything to save our country new
theories about the Downing of this jet
near Moscow what the Russian state says
is often very different from what's
happened and what Russia's president
said a
who led a mutiny against him
worries about treated water released
from Japan's Fukushima nuclear plant
why it's being done and how many decades
it will take
plus an exhausting and emotional
firefight I don't want to see my
hometown for a time a grateful BC
community's unbreakable spirit
global national with Donna freezing
former U.S president Donald Trump has
come and gone from Atlanta Georgia
surrendering himself at the Fulton
County Jail his fourth criminal
indictment this year and this time he
could not avoid having his mug shot
taken a first for any former or sitting
president he was arrested on 13 criminal
charges including racketeering and
conspiracy to commit false statements
accused of a conspiracy to try to
overturn his loss in the 2020
presidential election good evening and
thanks for joining us these are the most
serious of the 40 charges Trump faces he
was in and out of jail today quickly as
Bale said at two hundred thousand
dollars our Jackson prosco is there
Jackson what do we know about how the
arrest went
well Donna a couple big points to hit
here first and foremost he was given
essentially a presidential sized
motorcade from the airport here in
Atlanta to the Fulton County Jail that's
not something he's had previously in his
prior arraignments when he's had a much
smaller Entourage with him he was inside
the jail for about 21 minutes start to
finish as you mentioned a mug shot was
taken he has also been assigned a formal
prisoner number at this point he was
able to pre-self-report his own height
and weight with numbers we should point
out that do not match what he has
reported in person during his prior
arraignments the other thing to keep in
mind here now is that he is free tonight
on two hundred thousand dollars Bond but
he actually Enlisted the services of a
bond agency to post that for him meaning
they only put up a small portion of his
own money at this point Donna as you
mentioned a mug shot taken all this
marking another historic first for a
former president of the United States
and Jackson he will be going to trial he
also wants to be president again what do
we know about the timing of the trial
and can you run for president while on
trial
there's certainly nothing to stop him
from running for president while on
trial or running from president if he is
ultimately convicted and imprisoned
those things are very much possible
under the American Constitution and we
know that district attorney fonnie
Willis is pushing for a very speedy
trial here in fact one of the proposed
dates floated today October 23rd that's
just 60 days from now quite likely that
Trump's team is going to try and object
to this because of course they want to
slow things down but things are moving
ahead also pointing out that Trump's
former white house chief of staff Mark
Meadows among those who surrendered
among the 19 co-defendants in this case
Jackson this is a serious criminal case
13 felony counts and yet Trump
supporters say they don't care neither
do most of his Rivals vying for the
Republican nomination here's what
happened at the first Republican
presidential primary debate last night
which Trump skipped
well it tells you that they understand
the power and the grip that Trump still
has on the Republican Party look I've
been speaking to Trump supporters all
day long today outside the prison here
they say they stand with him they would
support him even if he is incarcerated
Trump knows it each indictment bumps him
further ahead of his political Rivals
and look he's the master media
strategist he turned himself in the day
after that debate and by doing so he's
got everyone talking about the arrest of
the party's front runner and not the
debate amongst the candidates who are
running against him
Jackson crosco in Atlanta Georgia
tonight thanks in Moscow Russian
President Vladimir Putin did not
explicitly confirm the death of Evgeni
pragosian today but he did call him a
talented man who had made mistakes
pagosian led a brutal mercenary group
that fought alongside Russian troops in
Ukraine but then turned on the Kremlin
directly challenging Putin's Authority
the Pentagon said today it's likely he
was killed when that private plane fell
from the sky near Moscow yesterday but
there's no evidence a missile took it
down the leading theory now is that
explosives were on board Crystal
gemancing Reports
a technical Aviation probe and criminal
investigation are underway according to
Russian media following the crash of
Evgeni pagosian's jet why his plane
carrying 10 people suddenly lost
altitude Wednesday isn't clear
Witnesses report hearing a loud bang and
seeing one of the wings fly off
while victim identification work is
underway memorials began to appear in
honor pagosian Dimitri ukin said to be
Wagner's co-founder and other members of
the militia
nearly 24 hours after the crash Russian
President Vladimir Putin expressed
condolences to the families of the
victims
Putin said this about progojit he
achieved the results he needed for both
himself and when I asked him for the
common cause alluding to his work in
Ukraine
Putin said he had known pragosian for a
very long time and called him a man with
a complicated fate many speculate the
Russian president had a role in The
Deadly crash but it's also possible
according to experts that progosian felt
he was in trouble after leading a mutiny
against Russian military leaders back in
June and faked his own death so often
Nothing Is What It Seems on the surface
and what the Russian state says is often
very different from what's happened in
real life
Ukraine's president wasted no time in
stating his country had no role in the
crash it's not out of the realm of
possibility that Ukraine or one of its
allies would be blamed for Downing the
plane
Global News London
today is Ukrainian Independence Day and
to Mark the occasion troops launched a
naval raid on russian-occupied Crimea
Ukraine Security Service released video
of the covert nighttime operation on the
western tip of Crimea soldiers say they
fought off Russian forces and raised the
Ukrainian flag before they fled
foreign
ER zelenski praised ukrainians for their
courage and Defiance today it is
Ukraine's second independence day since
the start of Russia's full-scale War
Ukraine declared independence from the
former Soviet Union in 1991. prime
minister Justin Trudeau spoke with
zelenski today he congratulated him and
reaffirmed Canada's support and one last
note on Ukraine natoka cimok has been
appointed Canada's ambassador to Ukraine
she has deep connections to ukrainians
here and abroad and will serve as
Canada's eyes and ears in Kiev in Japan
workers at the Fukushima nuclear power
plant have begun releasing treated
radioactive water into the Pacific Ocean
[Music]
it's a crucial step towards
decommissioning the plant that was
destroyed by an earthquake and tsunami
in 2011. the Japanese government signed
off on the controversial plan two years
ago it will take decades to complete and
as Mike Armstrong reports there is
strong opposition
doing nothing isn't an option after 12
years collecting tainted water at the
wrecked Fukushima nuclear power plant
they are now at capacity there are 1033
massive tanks on site and they've run
out of space the solution is a
controlled release into the ocean
continuing to just store it could be
dangerous if there's another earthquake
that water could spill from those tanks
and contaminate the area even more when
the 2011 earthquake and tsunami hit the
Fukushima plant three reactors melted
down and the facility was knocked
offline more than a decade later the
reactors still have to be cooled the
water used to do that becomes
radioactive there's also rain water and
groundwater now all of that water is
treated it's run through a filtering
system that removes almost all the
radioactive materials the process
doesn't remove a material called tritium
well the treated water with tritium is
diluted with seawater to make it
according to experts safe enough to
drink as it's released it's also being
diluted again with more sea water
tritium in it experts say won't be a
problem the amount that is allowed in
drinking water is more than what is
found in the water here that is to be
released now expert opinions haven't
stopped the protests this was South
Korea Thursday China already bans
Seafood imports from the Fukushima
region
it's now extending that ban to all
Seafood from Japan and calls the release
of the contaminated water selfish
this is something that's done at nuclear
facilities around the world including
here in Canada plants actually report
exactly how much tritium they're
discharging each week we're doing this
for 50 years and the amount of radiation
is is trivial
for those protesting this is an issue
that won't go away for a while there are
1.3 million tons of treated water to
discharge about 500 Olympic-sized pools
it's going to be released slowly over
the next 30 Years like Armstrong Global
News
in BC and out of control Wildfire is
still looming over residents in the shoe
Schwab the Bush Creek East wildfire in
the southwestern part of BC's shushwap
region is estimated to be more than 430
square kilometers in size about 4 600
properties are still under evacuation
order another 860 are on alert and not
everyone is happy about that
last night a tense moment at a
checkpoint a convoy had made its way
there intending to dismantle it in order
to help some people who refuse to leave
the evacuation Zone RCMP say the
situation was ultimately resolved safely
the underlying tension though remains
and with the weather expected to heat up
over the weekend people are being urged
to remain patient Jamie Dahl reports
gone is the laughter the splashing
children the summer Repose instead the
shores of shushwap Lake are lined with
the remnants of people's hard-built
lives raised to the ground in an instant
but some people have lost their homes
some people have lost their businesses
and some people have lost both so yeah
it's pretty heartbreaking the group of
locals who stayed behind are doing what
they can to prevent more loss here we're
just working when you're working you're
alert you're going right you're lurking
still in the same shoes Dan Roan is one
of dozens of ranchers contractors and
retirees wielding shovels and hoses
trying to protect properties and
livestock we work till whatever we
figure we got to depends on the fire and
then we shut her down and we got night
shift every two hours someone goes out
and does our where our guards aren't
checked but resident firefighters and
others who have stayed to support them
say they're facing another battle
the hardest part is not being able to
help each other like we sort of feel
like criminals you know like we're
trying to get food from one place to the
next and then we're getting stopped by
the police you know so it feels like
transporting drugs rather than food it's
not the fires anymore it's the
authorities that I fear RCMP say there
are more people not abiding by the rule
so they're increasing their presence in
this area we're at the point now where
we're not allowed up our property under
threat of arrest and you're off the
property right now I am you know I mean
God you know how far do you comply with
this kind of nonsense and you can see
all the hot spots still smoldering in
the forest locals who stayed who have
been volunteering to fight these fires
say that's a big reason why they will
not be budging we're not here to be in
anybody's way you know I would I go home
and watch TV I'm old like you know so
what the heck eh but uh but you know the
situation didn't warrant that so we had
to fight the deputy Regional fire chief
praised the enormous Community effort
but says it's time for the trained
professionals to take control of the
scene
we respect and we really appreciate the
desire to help we've had some instances
of threats abuse
theft of equipment
and other unfortunate about us
frustrating here for those with good
intentions here determined to help in
any way they can in a community yet to
really grasp the total scope of its loss
Jamie dog global news near Sorrento BC
in the Northwest Territories of fire
near Yellowknife hasn't moved closer but
people are not being allowed to return
because the winds are expected to pick
up today and tomorrow several police
checkpoints have been Turning Away
people trying to return home believing
the threat is over Fort Smith near the
Alberta border remains under an
evacuation order because the Wood
Buffalo complex fire is still out of
control just four kilometers from town
that same fire has also grown closer to
Fort Fitzgerald on the Alberta side of
the Border it's now just three
kilometers from that community
it was an agonizing 14 hours coming up
new drone video of that cable car
dangling precariously in Pakistan
this is excruciating to see its drone
video obtained by the BBC of that cable
car in Pakistan dangling almost 300
meters above a ravine the six children
and two adults braced themselves no
doubt fearing any move could make things
even worse after about 14 hours everyone
did get down safely some by helicopter
long lines others along a zip line the
owner of the cable car is facing
multiple charges including endangering
lives and negligence
well first it made history landing on
the moon's South Pole now India's Rover
is taking a walk the space agency said
the Rover ramped down from the lantern
began exploring the lunar surface it's
expected to operate for two weeks
Gathering data and images to be sent
back to Earth for analysis that could
help determine the viability of lunar
settlements in the future
helping Haiti ahead can the Caribbean
country rebuild from years of unrest
[Music]
Canada's ambassador to Haiti has ended
his two-year Mission the Caribbean
country is in a dire state with
widespread gang violence creating fear
and Chaos Dan Spector on the outgoing
ambassador's vision for Haiti and how
the troubled Nation may be able to
emerge from the crisis
[Applause]
Cry for Help from residents of
Port-au-Prince screaming for the Army to
help them deal with the criminal gangs
that are terrorizing this area and many
parts of Haiti
[Music]
I left my house without any clothes as
this woman my children have nothing my
home was burnt down sadly her story is
not unique gang violence has soared in
the country since the assassination of
President Joven and Moyes in 2021
regular citizens are caught in the
middle much of the country is not under
government control the UN says criminal
groups killed more than 2 000 people in
the first half of 2023 alone kidnappings
and rape are rampant it's as bad as I've
seen it this is the context in which
Sebastian Canada's ambassador to Haiti
for the past two years just said goodbye
to the troubled Nation this Mission
ended this week he's returning home to
Ottawa from Port-au-Prince it's really
hard to leave this place I love Haiti I
love the Haitian people there's so much
that we're doing and so much more to be
done is proud of the help Canada has
offered during his stint sanctioning Bad
actors funding humanitarian projects
that help feed hundreds of thousands of
school children provide assistance to
Farmers improve maternal Health you
listen a lot you consult and you try to
build Solutions yeah yeah thinks the key
to a stable Haiti long term is to better
equip the understaffed Haitian National
Police I think everything else sort of
you know devolves from that the Trudeau
government pledged 100 million dollars
to the Haitian National Police earlier
this year but members of the Haitian
diaspora in Canada are skeptical
training of the police it would be a
good thing but it's not gonna be enough
Chantal Isme points to the fact the
current government was not elected many
see them as illegitimate and corrupt top
officials have alleged links to
organized crime to her that undermines
the police they need to have um you know
be okay of the higher level which that's
where the problem is that's what I'm
saying
says he's been pushing for elections
something Isme wants to see immediately
but when that will happen is anyone's
guess the Ambassador admits the job was
hard work but says every day he drew
inspiration from regular Haitians Rising
above the chaos to live their daily
lives I get my daily dose of Courage
from the Asian they're extraordinary
they've endured things that us Canadians
cannot even imagine Dan Specter Global
News
grief and gratitude next mixed emotions
as the Smoke Clears over Kelowna
there is progress in the fight against
wildfires in BC's Kelowna area at least
two fires are now classified as being
held cooler temperatures and higher
humidity help Crews starting controlled
Burns today igniting pockets of brush to
burn away Fuel and new aerial shots
reveal the extent of the damage on both
sides of Okanagan Lake more evacuation
orders have been lifted in parts of West
Kelowna nitu garcha has been talking to
Residents grateful to have a home to go
back to
you know I'm important to raise
from the firefighters I was born and
raised Kelowna to the volunteers feeding
them many on the front lines near
Kelowna BC are fighting to protect their
own communities Larry watkinson says
it's been an emotional experience seeing
all these signs of gratitude I'm so deep
seated into the incident it's hard to
kind of look outside of what we're doing
operationally but now that we're winding
things down a little bit here it starts
hitting home a little bit more and
realizing the uh
we're all live in these communities
Kelowna Deputy fire chief Dwight Seymour
says the fires burned several of the
firefighters own homes when I heard that
a lot of their homes ended up not making
it that just shows the dedication and
they're still there they're still out
there fighting they're still doing it
travel restrictions to the area mean
several local Caterers and restaurants
are facing event cancellations they
donated food to the local Salvation
Army's portable food truck and kitchen
feeding them on the side of the road to
make sure that they could continue going
that level of Love is uh it's
overwhelming and I don't want to see my
hometown burnt out
this University campus was evacuated and
converted into a base camp for hundreds
of firefighters with progress on nearby
fires they're demobilizing here and
focusing on the flare-ups in other parts
of the region
firefighters in nearby West Kelowna
still working to extinguish hot spots
volunteers equipping a group lodging
space with more than 200 beds
and large shipments of donated food
coming in by the truckload to the
Kelowna Food Bank
the kids and the people coming up and
Thanking us uh that goes a long way we
don't always get that some people uh
some people think they know better but
we haven't seen that from our community
and our community's really stepped up he
says the character of the community is
coming together is shining through the
Dark Cloud of uncertainty in a fire
fight that's far from over nitu karcha
global news Kelowna BC
and that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna freeze and tonight's
your candidates this firefighter one of
many hard at work near West Kelowna BC
thanks for watching bye-bye
[Music]